from litter to lack of upkeep and
vandalism some residents are concerned
and have reached out to eight news now
about maintenance at parks all across
the valley sally jaramillo joining us
live this afternoon at jc park near
eastern and sahara with some of the
problems that she found today sally
christian today my photographer mark
zamora and i went all across the valley
looking at multiple parks and what we
found may surprise you garbage broken
glass damaged playgrounds graffiti and
dirty tables just to name a few
elena ledo is a mom of a nine-year-old
she frequents many valley parks she is
noticing more problems recently not as
clean as they used to be lido says it
doesn't matter what area of town or who
runs it but there is a lot of graffiti
and debris shelby mccully mom of a
ten-year-old agrees it doesn't matter
what park you go to you're gonna find
trash that's i mean that the cities like
i said are taking more care of the
bigger parts the more popular parts that
you're seeing everywhere it doesn't
matter what what park you go to you're
gonna find vagrants you're gonna find
trash and
they just they need to be more attentive
especially for our children both mothers
say they would like to see all
playgrounds being inspected and
sanitized once a week
becca live now if you do have a concern
about a park reported the county tells
me they have signs that parks with a
number the cities of las vegas and north
las vegas also have links to report
concerns now they do conduct regular
cleanings weekly reporting live sally
jaramillo live local now